hi guys I'm Reina I'm Ashley we're girls
got to eat and we're here to answer the
Internet
oh my gotta love this would you rather
have sex with a blind person or a deaf
person I feel like I'd rather have sex
the blind person I love dirty talk I
need somebody to ya I need somebody to
let me give me the warning shot when
they're close you know you can be blind
and then you can't see like what I look
like in the morning but I only want to
[ __ ] like I'm going blind I'm gonna be
like hi I'm Giselle like would you
rather have to tell your mom everything
you've ever done sexually or have to
show her your porn history I'll show my
mom my porn Esther she can see how the
lesbian box eating I want my mom knows
my whole sexual history we're real tight
like that yeah so yeah whatever she can
see what I watch porn wise - yeah my mom
and I'll talk about sex and then she'll
start I'm like you can't tell me mom
she's like oh this one time me and your
father like that's not how this works
it's a one-way street Mitch she called
me tell me about [ __ ] a hassle time
would you [ __ ] the ugliest teacher
you've ever had in order to [ __ ] the
hottest teacher you ever had this isn't
question for men I don't [ __ ] Carol
[ __ ] somebody else a hot a hot teacher
teacher the hot teacher did you ever
have a hot teacher yeah but guys a guy I
don't have [ __ ] the old lady in the
taught me biology in high school take
yet I think I would do it for the
content like I [ __ ] two of my teachers
the ugliest one of the hottest one like
stand up word solid on that like do it
for the content put in charge of running
hack the afterlife for people not evil
enough for hell what's the first torture
you designed by Apple it's in a
Nickelback I think having small talk
with people from high school yeah like
so what have you been up to
from people that's how you're right
would you rather watch your dad have sex
with a 100 year old man or watch your
mom kill someone watch my mom kill
somebody every day on top of that oh man
I feel like you want to watch my dad
have sex though yeah I'd love to watch
my mom kill somebody even without the
question yeah I just love murder like
love to watch women kill men as a person
what is the celebrity you most want to
see in a sex tape I don't know myself
I think the obamas I think Barack I want
to see how Barack gets it in yeah yeah
yeah see I'm happy Michelle is all the
time is absolutely Rockies [ __ ] no
doubt Brock's a giver I want it but I
think Michelle is gonna be great in bed
too
you can have one thing for free for the
rest of your life what do you choose
healthcare chicken fingers and unlimited
unlimited giving sausage chicken finger
would you rather have half your teeth or
half your hair well I don't my teeth are
fake so I don't have any teeth covered
up with veneer um I love my hair still
you can't not have teeth that is the
nothing's worse than bad teeth yeah I
mean you buy new hair on new teeth
actually would you rather never get back
from eating ever again or never have to
pay for any alcohol again I'm a girl to
pay for alcohol if you're paying for
drugs or alcohol you're at four you have
not used your present right if you are
paying for drugs or alcohol Rayna
Greenberg president 2020
okay my favorite drinks all the time I'm
reg oh my gosh I feel turned on would
you rather have dick fingers or vagina
ears okay follow-up question does it
smell your ear vaginas smell like of a
job do you have discharge you got your
period and you come out of either of
them come fingers come on your fingers
like spider-man but scum yeah I want to
see the porn between the guy with dick
fingers in the girl with vagina ears is
really really hot if you entered a
beauty pageant
what would your talent be always been
right Oh
[Laughter]
speed walking speed walk well I mean I'm
gonna just like I mean it's really like
I mean it's just like it's hard to get
it open
I'm Jewish
I just feel like I can just clean up you
are granted the ability to time travel
and visit your past self but you were
only allowed to speak ten words to your
past self one - what year do you go to
and - what do you say I think I would go
to 2010 and say don't I would say call
an uber so you don't get that third DUI
[Laughter]
I have one regret in life it's the third
D first you were I had those coming I
I'm glad you brought up tattoos I was
the back when I was 18 and say you don't
need a [ __ ] stamp it looks like a
bull's-eye just because you're finally
out of your parents house show it you
could live anyone's life with anyone's
body who would it be something we're
thinking bodies like maybe Emily
Ratajkowski yeah I feel like I could
just have anything I wanted if I had
those titties you know maybe I see her
all the time in the East Village with
her her life she I don't know she's from
New York she posted the other day about
a journey yeah she lives here with you
guys here with her husband her dog all
the time she is I mean yeah are like
LeBron I don't know I just want to yeah
I want to use that would you rather be
an extremely good-looking paralyzed
person or an absolutely hideous fully
functioning person I've thought about
this before I
why would just go with absolutely
hitting it's like I couldn't stand the
thought of like not are you paraplegic
or just quadriplegic 25 which which that
was paralyzed just hands though I'm
Giselle but I can only move my hands
upper body oh they're like t-rex no that
reason I'm out I would be in an ugly
person so you get surgery no you're
pretty again the crash look at Kylie and
Kendall when they were kids right
absolutely I would start like a charity
for ugly people you have one free throw
shot if you make it you get 1 million if
you miss it you can never text again do
you take the shot am i stole abroad I
absolutely would would I couldn't live
without tax Dean I wouldn't risk it
again to rich to bother this question
if you could make one movie character
real to date you who would it be a lad
and a love black I love brown guys I
love a pretty guy Aladdin Aladdin I was
like I hope they ask which cartoon I
would [ __ ] like I'm tapped out
usually reload I'm funny today it's
Ferris Bueller or something let me walk
that back Paul from The Wonder Years
anyone underage all the kids from
stranger thing a pigs orgasm lasts for
over 30 minutes a lion can have sex for
over 50 times per day which would you
rather be so 30 minute orgasms or 50
times per day
whoo I'm not trying to have sex 50 times
a month who is time yeah who it's time
for 50 times a day a 30 minute orgasm
I'm down with that
yeah I'm trying to do that every night
absolutely what is one rumor true or
false you'd want to spread about
yourself I like this and I'm 27 I don't
know I feel like people always already
say such nice things about me
[Laughter]
you